[Musique]
salut à tous depuis quelques années le
phénomène blake blog prend de l'ampleur
en france
transformant de façon régulière les fins
de manifestations notamment à paris en
émeutes
alors le black block c'est quoi c'est
qui d'où ça vient
où ça va autant de questions auxquelles
on va essayer de répondre aujourd'hui
tout d'abord le black block c'est quoi
ce n'est pas un parti ou une
organisation structurée contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait croire en écoutant
certains médias le black block c'est
avant tout un mode d'action une
stratégie auquel tout le monde peut
prendre part le principe est simple
le principe est simple le black block
est un regroupement d'individus masqués
habillés de couleurs sombres
ce qui donne une masse anonyme où il est
difficile d'identifier les participants
cet anonymat permet ensuite à ceux qui
le veulent seul ou en groupe de façon
improvisée ou bien préparés à l'avance
de mener des actions illégales ou
violentes en toute sécurité
certains y viennent avec des objectifs
précis la preuve il ya parfois des
tracts de coller revendiquant le cassage
de vitrine mais globalement ce n'est pas
un ensemble structuré pour autant la
plupart des gens qui participent à un
black bloc y viennent sans bien savoir
ce qui va se passer
au mieux on sait par des échos que ça
peut dégénérer et si ça dégénère et bien
on en profitera pour jouer les émeutiers
sinon tant pis les cagoules ont été
sortis pour rien encore une fois ce
n'est pas l'expression d'un party
organisée mais une masse qui permet à
des petits groupes ou à des individus
isolés d'avoir des actions qu'il ne
pourrait pas faire sans cette masse
anonyme pour les couvrir
par exemple le 1er mai 2018 on a annoncé
1200 black blocks à paris vous n'avez
pas mille 200 émeutiers mais 1200
personnes qui fournissent un anonymat et
ensuite un point de repli à ceux qui
veulent en découdre et politiquement le
black blocks et qui au niveau
idéologique
le black block regroupe tous les membres
les plus radicaux de l'extrême gauche
ceux qui refusent tout compromis avec le
système que ce soit le syndicalisme les
élections voire même tout simplement
déclaré une structure légale pour eux la
violence et l'action directe sont des
modes d'actions privilégiées
car contrairement à d'autres modes de
contestation plus institutionnelle ils
sont non récupérables par le système
dans un black bloc vous trouvez surtout
des autonomes plus communément appelée
totaux par le reste de la gauche
radicale
c'est une constellation à part entière
dans la galaxie d'extrême gauche avaient
c'est propre courant sous courants et
chapelles certains sont anar d'autres
sont marxiste tous déteste les
organisations politiques y compris
d'extrême gauche qu'il voit comme des
éléments modérateur des luttes des
récupérateurs qui brident l'esprit de
révolte des masses il croit à une forme
de spontanéité révolutionnaire même si
paradoxalement ce sont des gens qui
marchent en réseau informel aussi bien
structuré que des organes ne croyant pas
au jeu institutionnel des partis et
syndicats
la mouvance autonome à privilégier des
modes d'action directement en
confrontation avec le capitalisme et ses
valeurs par exemple l'ouverture de squat
à des fins d'habitation mais aussi de
diffusion des pratiques
contre-culturelle les autonomes n'étant
pas forcément des émeutiers
même s'ils sont bien moins nombreux en
france il faut aussi signaler la
présence de courant stalinien et en
particulier des maoïstes
c'est à dire le courant du communisme le
plus militariste et le plus fasciné par
la violence ce n'est pas pour rien si la
plupart des groupes qui sont passés à la
lutte armée ou au terrorisme s'en
revendiquent les maos on militaro par
nature et le black block est ce qui se
rapproche le plus pour eux de la
guérilla urbaine à ces deux grandes
mouvances
il faut aussi ajouter des gens radicaux
sans idéologie particulière qui évolue à
la marche de ces sphères et des casseurs
par opportunité
d'ailleurs ceux qui se sont arrêtés à la
suite de ces émeutes se sont rarement
des militants qui avaient préparé leur
coup les petits groupes organisés qui
commettent le plus de dégradations se
font rarement attraper bon on sait
maintenant qui ce qu'est le black bloc
maintenant d'où ça vient
le phénomène est né en allemagne dans
les années 80 et a été popularisé dans
les années 90 dans les manifestations
altermondialistes comme à seattle en
1999 en france c'est arrivé en retard
la première apparition réelle du
phénomène chez nous a été lors d'une
manifestation internationale entre
l'otan à strasbourg début 2009
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
la ville a pris très cher c'est
d'ailleurs suite à cet épisode qui a été
voté la première loi interdisant les
cagoules en manifestation mais la
première apparition franco française
elle a eu lieu à poitiers quelques mois
plus tard lors d'une manifestation
anticarcérale au cours de laquelle
plusieurs centaines de personnes
masquées ont saccagé le centre-ville
avant 2009
il y avait parfois des échauffourées en
fin de manif mais rien d'organisé ça
s'explique par le fait que la france a
une longue tradition organisationnel
l'extrême gauche il est structuré en
partie associations syndicats divers
groupuscules qui veulent tout se faisait
dans le champ politique sans se couper
des masses la violence n'est donc pas
une option réaliste et été condamné par
les organes pour moi il ya eu deux
étapes dans l'appareil
du black block en france d'abord dans
les années 2008 2010 plusieurs
événements qui conjugués ont remis sur
la table la question de la violence dans
l'action politique
d'abord la crise grecque la mouvance
anarcho-autonome violente et très
présente en grèce et à jouer fortement
sur l'imaginaire des jeunes
révolutionnaires français
et puis toujours selon moi il y aussi
une part de responsabilité de l'état
français à travers la gestion
catastrophique de la sphère de tarnac
rappelez-vous en 2008 un crochet est
posée sur une ligne de tgv et au passage
du train plusieurs centaines de mètres
de caténaire se retrouvent arracher le
gouvernement voulant montrer qu'il
maîtrise la situation quelques jours
plus tard un petit groupe de la mouvance
autonome
domicilié à tarnac est dirigée par un
certain julien coupat est arrêtée de
façon très médiatisée et traiter
quasiment comme des terroristes devant
le traitement hallucinant de cette
affaire une partie des médias prend fait
et cause pour le groupe
l' enquête sera un fiasco s'éternisera
s'enlisera et la sphère finir à dix ans
plus tard sur un non lieu
il se trouve que coupat et les siens
étaient surveillés par la police car il
était soupçonné très probablement à
raison d'ailleurs d'être derrière les
écrits du comité invisible un groupe
ayant produit des livres et des revues
appelant au sabotage et à l'insurrection
leur ouvrage phare l'insurrection qui
vient est écrit dans un langage poétique
aux révolutionnaires et leurs autres
productions comme la revue tiqqun dans
un style philosophique assez hermétique
des personnes de la mouvance autonome
ayant lu et compris ses textes m'ont dit
que ça leur faisait penser à du riz de
guerre il faut dire que coupât a fait
des études en philosophie avant la
sphère tarnac
les autonomes tendance insurrectionnel
était un milieu très réduit confidentiel
et après tarnac
une partie des jeunes d'extrême gauche
entrés dans le mouvement à cette époque
se sont mis à lire ses ouvrages et
coupat et ses thèses ont une visibilité
inespérée et depuis à tort ou à raison
chaque mouvement social les
renseignements généraux sur lake ou pas
il voit sa marque dès qu'il ya des
troubles coupe à lui écrit toujours des
livres sous pseudo qui sont bien plus lu
que ces anciens textes de façon plus ou
moins liés à la même époque
ressurgissent dans une partie de
l'extrême gauche des thèses
insurrectionnalistes et on a donc une
conjonction d'événements qui ont mis en
avant l'idée d'actions violentes chez
une partie de la jeunesse d'extrême
gauche en même temps que la propagation
de toute une littérature émeutière
jusque là très confidentiel pour vous
donner une idée du climat de l'époque
à ce moment là je militais dans une
organisation anarchiste rien de mes
camarades qui avait la petite vingtaine
alors rejoint un groupe autonome
tendance insurrectionnalistes qui
taquet les assemblées générales
étudiantes qui a également attaqué les
locaux syndicaux d'un syndicat étudiant
d'extrême gauche et ce camarade à
lui-même a fini par laisser femmes et
enfants derrière lui puisqu'il avait un
enfant en bas âge pour aller faire la
révolution en grèce alors certes ce
parcours n'est pas représentatif de
toute une génération militante mais en
tout cas et donne quand même une
indication sur les débats qui avaient
cours dans certains milieux et puis
deuxième étape dans l'apparition des
black blocks en france et surtout de
black blocks à la française la loi
travail en 2016 dans les manifs contre
la loi travail
on a vu apparaître à paris devant le
cortège officiel ce qu'on a appelé le
cortège de tête où tout le monde était
habillé en noir ce cortège de tête est
une mutation importante
ça a été une sorte de black blocks de
masse rassemblant largement au delà des
sphères autonome et marxiste ultra ce
cortège de tête a servi d'exutoire à
tous les déçus de la stratégie syndicale
qui voulaient en découdre
y compris à des syndicalistes de base il
faut dire que les directions syndicales
non plus obtenu de victoire depuis 2006
et la défaite sur les retraites en 2010
a fortement endommagé leur image et leur
capacité de mobilisation et clairement
des black blocs ou plutôt les cortèges
de tête qu'on a aujourd'hui en france
dans toutes les grandes manifestations
cette massification de la radicalité la
tolérance pour sa violence vient de
l'échec du mouvement social classique
depuis dix ans à faire barrage aux
réformes gouvernementales
l'action violente chez certains n'est
plus antagoniques à des modes d'action
plus institutionnel mais complémentaires
et ce au point qu'en 2016 pour la
première fois certaines structures et
intellectuels d'extrême gauche et pas
forcément les plus radicaux ont refusé
de condamner les violences validant à
leur manière les méthodes du cortège de
tête et depuis 2016 vous avez
régulièrement la présence de ce cortège
aux manifs y compris celles sans
importance stratégique comme celle de
rentrer sur le pouvoir d'achat par
exemple la violence dans le mouvement
des gilet jaune
le yellow bloc c'est le même schéma que
le cortège de tête des vrais black block
plus des personnes que le manque et au
vu de l'incapacité de la gauche
politique et syndicale institutionnels à
faire reculer les différents
gouvernements sur leurs réformes
le black bloc et la cortège de tête
honte à mon avis encore de beaux jours
devant tôt en tout cas j'espère que
maintenant vous y voyez plus clair sur
ce faire mieux blocs noirs
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à partager
cette vidéo est sur ce je vous dis à la
prochaine
[Musique]